one other thing I'll say and this is
where [ __ ] gets interesting mark please
fact check if you want to know how deep
this goes the current Attorney General
of the United States is William bar
right that's the guy that trump
appointed okay okay
Trump appoint william bar William Bar
tries to fire the New York State I
believe it was District Attorney Berman
New York Attorney General sorry the New
York Attorney General Berman okay
who's like really entrenched into like
the democratic scene of the DNC and
Democrat politics he tries to fire
Berman says family you're just the
sitting you're the interim Attorney
General you can't do that to me so the
Trump goes all right boom I'll fire you
so they fire him right
William Barr father Donald bar hired who
as a teacher at the Dalton School in New
York City Jeffrey Epstein hmm if you
want to know how deep this [ __ ] really
goes we're not talking about oh we found
some people doing a little sex
trafficking ring and we're gonna you
know go prosecute them or kill them or
do whatever it goes to the top all this
goes to the top and everybody involved
knows exactly what's going on a picture
came out this week of Gillian Maxwell
and Kevin Spacey mm-hmm sitting on the
throne the royal throne in Buckingham
Palace okay they were there in
Buckingham Palace as guests of Bill
Clinton and I believe the Rothschilds
perhaps on the fur right I think it's
mentioned in it it said I thought they
were they were invited by the dude
Edwards or whatever who we want to speak
to but he's like I'm not speaking to
anybody right now
Oh Prince Andrew yeah Prince Andrew what
Clinton was there yes they were guests
of Clinton oh right and I believe the
Rothschilds as well right so you want to
add Rothschild family that's global
banking right yeah you look at Prince
Andrew who is scared for his [ __ ]
life of being caught up into this this
so now you have the royal family
a family protecting Prince Andrew but
now they're all friends you have this
random actor Kevin Spacey who is accused
of sexual assault by multiple people
recently right and that's where we put
those weird videos out mark how many of
his accusers randomly ended up dying oh
yeah three of his accusers have done so
three of these accusers what yeah it's
crazier it gets crazier son
so Kevin Spacey gets called out for
sexual assault three of the accusers
randomly end up that maybe one is a car
crash a couple other little situations
Mark Wilson couple from suicide a couple
little suicides yes yes someone I heard
that story cuz I was like oh [ __ ] he's
really playing the character on that
show that mark would you mind telling us
when so for he put out those videos
after he was accused as Frank Underwood
right yeah mark could you tell us some
details about those videos that are
quite interesting oh yeah in the videos
people are saying that the mug he's
using is a from like the Royal like from
Buckingham Palace that it has like royal
family insignias on the mug and that
apparently he puts on a ring at the end
which some people are suggesting is a
freemasonic ring kind of is like like
allusions to the people he's speaking to
which would be the royal family and he's
basically saying you know y'all better
clear this up yeah
y'all better yeah I'm not taking the
fall for this y'all better clear it up
and he did the video as Frank Underwood
now what is Frank Underwood based on
Frank Underwood his wife are based on
the Clintons right that's the loose
assumption now it's basically it was an
old English TV show actually which is no
but the characters within American
politics
I think the first season at least are
like whatever it's a pretty it's based
off in English oh right right with but
the fact that they're like mirror and
whatever doesn't you think okay I think
they're mirroring off of certain Clinton
[ __ ] but it doesn't matter let's let's
excuse that cut it outlet so it doesn't
you know we can't cut the legs off
anything you're talking about people now
granted who is Kevin Spacey right and a
[ __ ] nobody actor he just happens to
be ruffling feathers or like you know
what is it rubbing shoulders whatever it
is with these very powerful people and
they can kind of tie up loose ends and
he makes one [ __ ] video and then all
these accusers go advantage if they die
after the video I I mean it's crazy all
three of them died regardless and I
think that's beyond coincidental
I would be curious to know if it was hey
you think the wedding said there the
video I mean Center we can look and find
the timelines and that being said you
don't got to make a video to get them
out of here mm-hmm right he do make a
phone call to get them out here but
another thing very important to note has
anybody else accused Kevin Spacey since
those people died no no I wouldn't I
mean would you if the three other people
that accuse him end up dying would you
nice this is how deep this [ __ ] goes so
when you think Golay maxwell is caught
in apprehended and she didn't know any
better and she's in New Hampshire this
[ __ ] was in France [ __ ] was in Brazil
this [ __ ] was in Israel
she couldn't be extradited in certain
places and chose to come back to New
Hampshire cuz they told her to and if
she sells on anybody it's because that's
Eleanor too
[Applause]